hop
[Musique]
c'est dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source que s'est déroulée la première
réunion du conseil départemental de
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation de lutte contre les
drogues et les dérives sectaires
une réunion de travail animé par le
préfet de la réunion en sa qualité de
président et du président du département
ainsi que du procureur de la république
en leur qualité de vice président les
deux axes prioritaires c'est la
prévention du basculement dans la
délinquance des 10-13 ans et ça passera
par l' échange d'informations accrue au
sein justement des clspd y compris
nominative dans un cadre sécurisé des
changes d'information pour lutter par
exemple contre le décrochage scolaire
qui est un élément très important à
prendre en compte
le deuxième c'est une constante mais
nous continuerons
je dirais plus que jamais de le prendre
en compte c'est mieux prévenir mieux
lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales et ça ça passe
effectivement je dirais bien sûr dans la
poursuite de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes mais pas que
puisque nous souhaitons aussi faire de
la lutte contre les violences à
l'encontre des personnes âgées une
priorité et puis dernier point nous
avons j'irai définit un axe pays
ce sera le troisième axe un axe pays et
là pas de surprise puisque il s'agira de
lutter contre l'alcool
l usage des stupéfiants et de réduire la
place de l'alcool dans l'espace public
pleinement engagé dans ce conseil la
collectivité départementale chef de file
de l'action sociale accompagne les
publics vulnérables et réalise également
des actions de sensibilisation pour
lutter contre les addictions
un des thèmes abordés ce jour notre
évolution fait
celle qui est lié à la révolution de des
stupéfiants pour consommer la réunion
historiquement ces mises à mal et des
médicaments qui ont détourné les 4 5 ans
on voit une arrivée intimement
importantes attaques -essentiellement
par par avion mais aussi par bateau est
très belle affaire ou produites par
l'ado émergents aimeraient ya quelques
jours lui démontre vous avez maintenant
de la cocaïne
la résine de cannabis et d
l'ecstasy votre dma qui sont consommés
par toutes les tranches sociales en mai
femmes souvent les ya de l'alcool donc
là on a ri tellement d'addiction et
quand vous êtes
armateurs habituelle de ce type
d'éducation pour financer votre
consommation
vous risquez de commettre des faits
graves d'atteintes aux biens aux
personnes les phénomènes comptes rendus
des gens métropole en effet rarement ici
à l'issue de cette réunion un travail
collaboratif sera initiée avec
l'ensemble des acteurs afin d'élaborer
un plan local de prévention de la
délinquance répondants spécificités du
territoire
il sera adopté en juin à l'occasion de
la prochaine réunion du conseil
départemental de la prévention de la
délinquance
[Musique]